l'émotion en Corée ou des familles se
sont retrouvées après plus de 50 ans de
séparation une centaine de Nord-Coréens
ont pu se rendre au sud d'autres ont
fait le chemin inverse Nora boubetra
oh papa si seulement maman pouvait
encore être là à tes côtés il ne s'était
pas vu depuis près de 50 ans ce matin un
Séoul entre il n'y avait plus ni Corée
du Sud ni Corée du Nord mais juste un
fils qui retrouve un père âgé
aujourd'hui de 91 ans c'est sans doute
le moment le plus fort et le plus
symbolique de ce que les Coréens
appellent la semaine de réconciliation
la rencontre de ces familles la première
depuis 15 ans et l'une des mesures clés
du rapprochement décidé en juin dernier
lors du sommet historique entre les
leaders des deux Corées retrouvez ses
proches les embrasser tous n'ont pas eu
cette chance aujourd'hui le centre de
conférence de Séoul n'acceptait pas plus
de 5 membres par famille qui m'est donc
resté dehors pour apercevoir son frère
son frère
je suis si contente de le voir je pleure
parce que j'étais tellement contente
c'est comme si je rencontrais mon père
et ma mère aujourd'hui à Séoul comme à
Pyongyang les mêmes scènes d'émotion ici
aussi c'est une centaine de Sud-Coréens
qui ont fait le voyage pour une
rencontre qui ne durera que quatre jours
quatre jours pour rattraper près d'un
demi-siècle de séparation un premier pas
qui devrait normalement être suivi
d'autres puis de 7 millions et demi de
sud-coréens ont des parents au nord